今日はこちら cd カフェです
ブーン
ん
1分
相変わらず言葉の勉強についての話ですけれども
第4の医療
牛木であればぜひあの登録してください
8の金のところでキックすれば
知らせが
不届けますそれからまた
臨機でぜひ木と一緒に言葉を勉強してください
今日のテーマはですね
あのどうやってその勉強した言葉
おおおおそのどうやって維持するかとというテーマなんですよ
僕の場合は今一生懸命マーラー鼻あご勉強したりえって同時に映写語も勉強したり
協力を語も勉強したり
0そしてまあ
今までですね
に二か国語ですね勉強したことがあるんですよ
みんな同じ数順ではないんですよ
多分
エマール
5つ6つぐらいはまあまあ流暢にやらせる後マヨつもの陸奥ぐらいが
それでもまぁ通じると分かるとねあとはもう一時的に
例えばグリー章行く前にバギー消防8ヶ月間の間に間に食味勉強して
銀賞に行った時にギリシャ語で話しできたとあるいは露メディアでも同じくだったん
ですけれどもあるいはチャコ
しかし今はじゃあ
今すぐこの着後あるいはポーランド語文書語で話ししなさいと言われたら
できないとコマ
だから愛問題はじゃあいい勉強した言葉をどうやって位置するかという問題ですね
まぁ日本の場合はまあ
日本と正やはり日本という国はマージン部が多いわけですよ
ですよねえ
1億
ですから1よく
いつもん
ハーディンとに5メディアに1億2千
500万ですよね
人工だからもう日本語でも十分通じるわけですよ
北米でも英語で通じるマーロウ者である15号でその国の国語では十分通じると
いろんなその言葉を勉強する必要はないと
ヨーロッパでは隣の国ではいやードイツ語とかフランス語とかスペイン語とかイタリア
語で
話しているわけですからあ
滅
の3つ4つ5つの言葉を勉強する人たち方も少なくはないけれども
あるいは私のようにも式だから
20問
の言葉を勉強したわけですけれども
そのゆる問題は同じなんですよじゃあ日本でね
英語を勉強してしかし2年間何もしてない
学校の時にある位はロンドンで滞在した時に
者英語勉強いくかなりの主従まで猛勉強者の
できたわけですけれどもその今10年間使ってないとどうするかという
この問題についてはですね僕のその態度はですね
その勉強した言葉をその維持することは一切考えないと
その言葉はまた勉強したいときに
あああああ
使わなくちゃならないとかこの国行くからとかね
その時にもう一度勉強し始めます
そしてもう一度前に勉強した内容
特に今コンピュータの時代ですからすべての塩 p さぁん
すべてのその内容が持っているわけですから
それにもう一度戻ってですね
もう一度勉強するとですね数分戻ってきます
最初はちょっと難しいといろんなたんどを忘れましたけれども
それのあのやはり脳はねぇ
一度覚えて一度覚えた忘れた物は
もイヒ度あの覚えるとですね
前よりも良くあの
を知ってるわけですよしっかりした形でんもう脳にも凝る残るんですよ
だけ
北署の経験はたくさんあの何回もやったことあるんですよ
だからあの
ずっとこの言葉を
も勉強してないとしかし23年後もう一度これを勉強し始めました
ん
最初は難しいけれどもすぐ前よりも良いと
したの
龍驤と聞きやすいと
だから
僕の場合はまあに近く後にそれだけの時間とまぁの力ですね努力を
持ち越したと
しかしそれが僕にとってはそれは財産ですよ
それがすべての財産それは
畑職人一応
あのー
肥料だかいい
タネをまいたと肥料とカニ蔵
それにかけましたとし今はちょっとこうなったと
しかしもう一度行くと
もう一度肥料と水をかけますと元通り
あるいはもうとよりもいい形になりますそれは銀行の財産だから一切それを心配する
ことはないそういう
際さそういう古い友達があるほど
豊いつでも必要に応じてあるいはその頃見によってですね
それをもう一度訪ねてみるとやはりすぐ回復できます
だから
その勉強してそして長い間猛勉強してないタッチしてない
その言語ね言葉を維持するという
し必要というから心配は僕の場合はないですそれは今日のビデオろ
テーマです
さよなら
bea
うんん
5分
ブー